people are seeing all the
inconsistencies and the nonsense and now
we're seeing and people have been
waiting for this a long time we are
seeing minorities leave the Democrat
Party which was happening under Trump
right black men moving to the Republican
Party doubled I believe under Trump a
little bit less for black women uh
here's CNN's Tapper Jake Tapper uh
talking to bakari sellers who's a former
South Carolina state representative
talking about what's going on with black
men right now
a voter I can tell
you the lack of enthusiasm in our state
right now I don't feel and see the
enthusiasm that I think voters across
Georgia should have right now and I know
that oftentimes in midterm elections uh
people don't turn out to vote I hope
that won't be the case uh this year in
Georgia she's talking about Democratic
voters yeah no and I mean I think she's
sounding the alarm just as many people
have been doing but it ain't just
Atlanta I mean it's Philadelphia in the
race in Pennsylvania uh it's Cleveland
in the race uh with Tim Ryan and JD
Vance it's Orlando in Miami and Val
deming's race and so Democrats have to
do a better job particularly and I can't
wait for my phone to blow up after I say
this but particularly with black men I'm
like you just can't come to black men on
a after Labor Day and say come vote for
us every two years there has to be a
more direct
engaged approach with black male voters
who by all intents and purposes after
African-American women are the second
largest turnout base and that's just
something that we haven't done forever
and it drives me crazy you're in Ohio
tell us I am and I I'm amen and what
bakari is saying I mean the Democratic
party often leaves out the whole swath
of black men and black men matter to
their votes matter and they are very
much an integral part of the success of
the democratic party and so bottoms is
absolutely right the enthusiasm Gap is
there and we got to do a better job
call me crazy guys but I think that uh
black people are just like white people
I think white people are just like Asian
people I think Asian people are just
like Indian people from an American
context I think people like Law and
Order I don't think people like feeling
like if you're going to go on the subway
or walk down the street you're going to
be mugged or shot or pushed into a
subway car or whatever it might be I
think people are looking at it
regardless of their skin color and going
Democrats wanted to defund the police
well look what happened in New York City
under that Democrats want illegal
immigration in sanctuary cities well
look what happened to this city under
that and I think people are realizing it
and I think they're realizing it real
fast and I don't think the Democrats
have anything left they will have some
sort of surprise because they're evil
but I don't think they have anything
left when it comes to Saiyan policy